my previous lessons looked at arguments
and truth in logic and they introduced
the difference between truth and
validity in evaluating an argument as
you may have noticed neither the
language of logic nor the ways of
forming and analyzing an argument
guarantee the truth of the statements
the premises and conclusion within that
argument the toolkit of logic doesn't
generate truth instead it allows
statements to remain true throughout the
process of developing an argument we
might call it truth preserving rather
than truth producing we can analyze the
function of every one of the operators
you learned in the logic as a language
series within that context of truth
preservation this is normally done using
something called a truth table so far
speaking generally I've been careful to
separate content from form now let's
move towards integrating these two
aspects of statements by considering
truth values I'll be using just two
basic values true and false to start
with a simple analogy this is like a
light switch with the value on or off
the switch sends a signal to a light
which may also be on or off
the switch is a variable in a statement
like a proposition P the light is the
value of the entire statement if I give
you two statements P and Q can you tell
me what they mean no because they're
just variables and you don't know what
they represent so then can you say
nothing about their content think for a
moment in the lesson on arguments we
looked at an argument with the form P
implies Q P therefore Q it's well-formed
meaning if we fill it with true
statements the conclusion will be in
it is possible to say something about P
then it can be true or it can be false
and the same goes for Q by looking at
the operators in the form of the
argument we can pass that truth down to
the conclusion well we don't know the
specific value of P or Q we can say
things that hold for every possible
truth-value in combination and declare
the resulting truth value of the
statement as a whole if P is true then
the statement P is true if P is true and
Q is true then the statement P and Q is
true if P is false and Q is false P and
Q is false C you can say something about
the truth of these statements we're
going to dive into specifics but first
let's test to see if you get the gist of
logical values assume P and Q stand for
two different random propositions or
sentences I'm going to give you a value
for P and a value for Q and you'll tell
me if the statement that follows is true
let's say we have a proposition P I'm
going to bring back our light switch
analogy P is a switch and P can be on or
off
the negation not turns the value of P
around if P is true then not P is false
and vice versa if we add another not the
negation is negated so not not P is true
when P is true and false when P is false
the conjunction and joins two
propositions so you have to pay
attention to both of their truth values
P may be true when Q is true false when
Q is true and so on as we've seen before
the statement P and Q will only be true
if both P and Q are true in all other
cases it is false the light is lit only
when both switches are on inclusive or
is true when either P Q or both P and Q
are true the light goes on when at least
one switch is flipped on the other hand
exclusive or expects that either one or
the other statement is true but is false
when both statements are true as a
reminder this is the kind of or you use
when you ask do you want to leave today
or tomorrow where you exclude the
possibility of today and tomorrow the
light turns on when either one of the
switches is flipped
the logical implication is frequently
used and for some learners it's a bit
tricky if P is true then Q is true
meaning P implies Q holds if P and Q are
both true P implies Q is false if P is
true and Q is false in that case P
wouldn't imply Q it would imply not Q if
P is false and Q is false then P could
still very well imply Q so the
implication holds true the last case
where P is false and Q is true is an
interesting one something besides P
might imply Q so the implication still
holds P implies Q holds true unless P is
true and Q is false this is like a light
that goes on when switch P is on if the
switch is on then we expect the light to
be on but the light might also turn on
from some other switch so the switch P
being off doesn't make the statement if
P's flipped on then the light is on
untrue only one thing can make that
statement if P is on the light is on
false turning P on and finding the light
off
finally the by conditional means that
the two propositions P and Q have the
same value the statement P if and only
if Q is true when both P and Q are true
or both P and Q are false in any other
case the by conditional is false this
makes the two propositions logically
equivalent so they must return the same
value
I encourage you to go back through these
operators filling in P and Q with
propositions you take to be true or
false and spend some time reflecting on
the logical truth values of the
resulting statements this will be a good
exercise it'll help you familiarize
yourself with truth tables and clear up
some ambiguities in your logic please
take a moment to check out the playlists
on my youtube channel or the lessons on
native Lankin for more logic and
language resources as always thanks for
learning with me